now Tick Tock CEO showed Z2 is
testifying before the U.S House Energy
and Commerce Committee he's facing
questions about the social media
platform's alleged relationship with the
Chinese Communist party and its use of
data Colin Baker explains how Tech talk
and other social media platforms use
data
Tick Tock is a leader in grabbing
people's attention to do this it needs
lots of their data users need to give
access to their phone's camera
microphone photos video contacts
location information and to their
behavior online now this is all similar
to what other major social media
companies ask for too this is an
industry practice as a whole to violate
our rights to privacy to sell ads and
this is why we need strong data
protection rule to end this damaging
attitude that everyone is breaching
privacy so why shouldn't we most of us
know about cookies which put code from
the web onto our devices companies also
use what's known as a pixel tracker to
keep tabs on users as they browse the
web these are bits of code hidden as
Tiny images and web pages or emails that
report back to the company when you
visit pixels are deployed by most big
companies on most websites they're not
always consented to but they are mostly
legal in a study by ferroot a Canadian
Security Company pixel trackers from
Tick Tock were found across the web as
were pixel trackers from the other major
social media Giants
but tick tocks were also found on
government websites that did not know
they were there and the U.S government
has fined two American Health companies
for using pixels to track users while
they were looking at sensitive personal
health websites you started with a
violation of privacy by just following
people by by following people online and
trying to know what they're doing but
once you get insight in those habits
then the company have an interest to try
to see how they can exploit that and
Company May exploit that to sell you
more ads but then other actors May
exploit that to you try to to change
your political view tracking is now a
big part of our browsing experience
because our data has become the most
valuable commodity for companies
oh Mike Hannah's been listening in to
show z2's testimony for us Mike what's
been happening
well the chief executive officer has
faced a very hostile grilling over the
past 19 minutes largely hostile from all
members of the committee this is ongoing
uh the basic point was accusations that
Tick Tock is controlled by China than in
fact shares its data with China now this
was denied strongly by the chief
executive officer who denied that the
data is shared with the Chinese
government or indeed even with the
parent company bite dance these were
very serious accusations the FBI
director was in Congress recently and
said that Tick Tock presents a national
security issue this was a tenor of many
of the questions asked of ishuzi Chen
and certainly a very very hostile
questioning from the members of the
committee in the course of the morning
was tick tock's defense
well the chief executive officer
insisted that Tick Tock was taking
measures to ensure that its data did not
move outside the U.S for example he is
outlined a project called the Texas
Project in terms of which all the
servers would be brought within the
United States they would be supervised
by a U.S tech company and they would be
constantly examined by independent uh
observers he says very clearly that this
is something that no other media company
has offered no other tech company has
offered however this was largely pushed
aside because those in the committee
asking very closely about what is
happening now with tick tock not what it
proposes to do in the future there have
also been those observers who contend
that this is a freedom of speech issue
that to Outlaw Tick-Tock would be to
infringe the First Amendment of the U.S
Constitution then there are those
perhaps cynical who are arguing that the
U.S authorities are using all these
issues against Tick Tock to re-assume
U.S ownership of the company and
therefore thereby reclaim U.S dominance
in the tech sector something which uh
Tick Tock being in China is denying the
U.S at present okay Mike Hannah many
thanks for keeping us across events
they're in Washington well Chris stokel
Walker is a tech and digital culture
writer and the author of the book Tick
Tock boom China's Dynamite app and the
superpower race for social media and he
joins us now from Newcastle upon Tyne in
the UK thanks very much for being with
us showed Zu he's prepped endlessly for
this Committee hearing how do you think
he's doing so far
I think that he had a pretty rough
barracking at the start uh you know
these people who are part of this
committee are kind of pretty much
already decided I think on what they
think of tick tock and they're deciding
to use this almost as a staging post for
getting across quite how angry they are
of course we have to bear in mind that
there are larger geopolitical issues
around this and the discomfort around
you know the first kind of major social
media platform of origin outside of the
United States starting to become a big
thing uh it has been a really tough time
at the minute and quite a lot of heat
and not a lot of light into actually
what some of the issues are how real is
the US's fear that Tick Tock might make
some private data of U.S users
accessible to the Chinese government
holding that fear is absolutely fine and
absolutely valid but uh there is very
little actual evidence of that in fact
non whatsoever of some of the more
outlandish things that have been said
and it has been notable uh just quite
how Tech alliterate a lot of these
questions have been asking for instance
um the CEO of tick tock to to answer
relatively complex questions of how
algorithms work and how data processes
and and transfers work which are very
very concerning again these are things
that we need to get answers to but you
can't answer them as has been asked in
this hearing with a yes or a no which is
kind of doing a disservice I think to
both Tick Tock because they want to get
across their point of view but also to
those who really want to try and
understand whether those fears are real
and worth pointing out so far no real
evidence that these things that are
being claimed are actually true and Tick
Tock does of course to neither because
the other fear of course is that Tick
Tock has the potential to manipulate its
users is with the algorithm and and
predict and provide what it wants to
show to people that you know it it some
people would say that that's not also
possible it's not really realistic what
was your opinion there because this is
something that most social media
companies can do anyway
yeah and I think that's that's the key
thing
um the idea that social media networks
and platforms can manipulate us into
consuming content that we maybe didn't
know we wanted to watch is a real risk
it's also not one that's unique to tick
tock we have seen Mass manipulation
campaigns on all platforms of all
origins in the past and I think you know
some of this kind of headwind behind
tick tock's ban is a bit misguided
because ultimately you know if the
Chinese Communist Party really wanted to
try and overthrow the West which is what
some of these more outlandish statements
seem to claim they could do that quite
as easily through state-sponsored
campaigns on Twitter on Instagram on
Facebook indeed they do try that already
so I don't really buy this concern that
does seem to be shared by kind of the
more stride and anti-china Hawks in the
US that that this is somehow a unique
proposition for tick tock what is
interesting as well is this is quite a
bipartisan issue isn't it there's people
across the board who a pretty wary of
tick tock we've got the Biden
Administration saying that the company
could potentially be sold to a U.S
company and if it's not then it could
face a potential ban but either really
realistic
uh not really and that's in large part
because uh there are two sides to this
story uh you know Tick Tock does still
have some links to China uh in terms of
its business and uh just in the same way
that the United States can put export
bans on you know companies leaving its
country uh China can do the same and you
know the Commerce Secretary in China
came out earlier today and said that
they would be minded to oppose any
forced shotgun sale of tick tock to a
U.S entity um which leaves The Tick Tock
in a kind of invidious position I I
don't think it necessarily would want
and welcome that Chinese statement which
kind of proves the point here that we're
trying to get across which is if this
was a deep State Communist Party plot
then they would surely be kind of uh you
know not getting involved in it quite so
much they would want to be you know
making the path smoother for tick tock
to try and ingratiate itself into the
West rather than making it more
difficult really interesting to speak to
you Chris so Walker thanks very much
taking the time to join us